we just got the first benchmarks on
Apple's M3 lineup of chips that they
announced and let me tell you I am way
more impressed than I thought I would be
I mean this is absolutely insane now
there are a few benchmarks that are kind
of disappointing and we're going to talk
about that but I think Apple has some
really nice machines coming up now I
want to start out with the M3 chip this
is the one that's going into that $1600
14inch MacBook and I've said many times
I'm very impressed by this machine even
though people are complaining that it
still comes with eight gigs of RAM it's
still a great value and our score comes
in at
3,076 for single core score and
11,863 for multicore now that is an 18%
gain in single core over the M2 Chip and
that is a very very high very impressive
score now what has changed is not only
the fact that we have 3 nanometer but
the clock speed now is at
4.05 compared to 3.5 with the M2 and
then the M1 was 3.2 so this is the
biggest increase we have gotten in these
Apple silicon chips now we will see what
the thermals are going to be like the
temperatures when we test out all the
crazy Macs that I ordered so make sure
you guys are subscribed now in multicore
we have a difference of over 20% about
22% so that is also very good because
the actual core counts they are all the
same and with that that number right
there kind of shocked me because it is
close to the 14-in M2 Pro Mac that sold
for
$22,000 that one was at 12,800 for
multicore so slightly faster and with
that we also had a much slower single
course speed so we have improvements
there and of course the M3 chip has a
lot of other advantages so M3 is
actually performing quite well now as
far as graphics performance we have 47,6
651 and if you don't remember what we
got with M2 well this is a bit
disappointing that is only a 5%
difference compared to the unbinned M2
Chip getting a score of
45,000 and that is really weird because
at the event Apple said that it is 20%
faster compared to the M2 not 5% faster
so what gives well Apple talked about
retracing and all the other benefit
benefits and it could just be that this
uh kind of tests that are being run here
for compute they are not utilizing extra
kind of benefits and we're seeing just a
very minimal gain and then comparing it
to the 14-in M2 Pro that got 73,000 so
about 50% better performance in terms of
that RAW graphics power now we do have a
little bit more info using a different
program here are the results from Puget
bench running Photoshop and and overall
we have a 52% higher score than the M2
Chip with a 38% higher score in graphics
alone that right there is real world
results in a program that's very complex
and what's even crazier is compared to
the M2 Pro we have 20% better as far as
a CPU and 10% better in terms of
Graphics so don't just trust basic
benchmarks that might not utilize all of
that performance now as for the M3 Pro
unfortunately we have no benchmarks at
all and that might be on purpose because
at the event Apple quoted that being 20%
faster in terms of CPU than the M1 Pro
and the reason they didn't compare it to
the M2 Pro is because the M2 Pro was
also 20% faster than the M1 Pro it is
the same because Apple actually got rid
of performance cores replacing them with
efficiency cores and that kind of
negates having the 3 nmet updated design
and the transistor count also went down
so that's probably why apple is not
sending out M3 Pro uh testers to people
that are getting review copies but on
the other hand with the M3 Max this
thing is a beast we have multiple
results and this one right here has the
highest single core score
3,151 that is crazy high now the
multicore score on this one is slightly
lower than the other ones so not sure if
it's just because of temps or what's
happening so looking at this result uh
here we have
2,084 and I don't know if that says
anything to you but it is crazy that is
45% faster than the M2 Max in terms of
multicore talk about that update coming
out what 9 months later since the M2 Max
came out absolutely crazy it makes me
regret buying this laptop right here the
M3 Max absolutely smokes the best AMD
laptop that comes in at
16,720 and then if we compare it to the
best Intel laptop and this thing is a
super thick Beast that thing gets
18,957 that is over 11% faster and what
you have to remember is that this is in
a thin MacBook that can maintain this
performance on battery power compared to
to the Windows laptops which your
performance will go down sometimes by
half if you have it unplugged and then
you'll still get about an hour of
battery life cuz those things suck power
taking this a step further if we look at
the top Mac chart the brand new M2 Ultra
that came out about 4 months ago that
also scores
21,000 just slightly higher than this
laptop now for the price you're paying 4
grand for that and I bought one of those
for our main editing computer but in
this laptop you get the trackpad the
keyboard the amazing display the
speakers the battery because it's on the
go the portability for that same price
and you can run that on battery that is
mindblowing now if we take a look at the
best desktop processors right here you
will see that they're also coming in at
21,000 this one's
21,700 um that list just kind of goes
down we have 6 four core epic processors
on there scoring the same as a laptop
and comparing it to the processor that
AMD said was the best that thing gets
19,731 watts compared to the MacBook
that's going to be running at 60 Now
intel also released their brand new 14
900k processors that need liquid cooling
to run at factory specs that thing
literally is a 6 GHz processor and that
thing will pull almost 300 watts of
power that desktop if properly cooled
gets
22,400 score barely faster than a laptop
and that's running at 6 GHz water cooled
that is absolutely crazy good job apple
on this new chip now as far as Graphics
we only have a few open CL scores
available nothing yet for metal and in
terms of gfx bench we actually have a
result there it's roughly 19 20% faster
than the M2 Max um so not a huge
difference but once again this is not
counting the rate tracing that they
added any of the other benefits that
they talked about so we will have to see
how it performs in the real world but
overall other than the M3 Pro which was
not given out as a review and we'll see
how that performs I am thoroughly
impressed and I can't wait to get my
hands on them so make sure you guys
click that subscribe button above so you
guys don't miss out check out one of
those great videos right over there this
has been Max and I will see you in the
next
[Music]
one